[Music]
ten
amazing tips to nail the perfect steak
tip number one take the protein out of
the refrigeration unit and let it rest
to get up to room temperature for at
least 10 minutes
before you cook it number two season it
heavily because you lose 35 percent of
the seasoning the minute it goes in the
pan
so salt pepper freshly ground pepper
roll it in the seasoning
and then literally season it again just
before it goes to the pan
number three make sure
when placing the steak into the pan on
the grill you lay it away from you
never drop it towards you before you're
splashing hot oil on your arms
and you've got more control when you're
laying away
tip number four for me it's all about
the searing
make sure you have an amazing sear on
that steak
and don't turn it unless it's colored
remember no color no flavor
number five think about fragrance
ladies especially when you dress up
beautifully you put some
perfume on men you wear aftershave i
treat my steaks the same way
aromatics garlic thyme and rosemary
if you can put some garlic in there some
thyme and rosemary it'll make that steak
way more fragrant number six for me this
is a super important tip
put a tiny knob of butter into the pan
before you take that steak out and make
sure you baste it with that butter
let the butter caramelize and it gives
that really nice nut brown
flavor on top of that steak number seven
the minute you take the steak out of the
pan or off the grill you have to let it
rest
i promise you now if you let it rest
it's gonna be so much
juicier number eight
when slicing a steak never slice it too
thin
to maximizing the flavor and to keep it
moist
keep it at least half a centimeter thick
tip number nine for me is the most
important one it's about the temperature
you'd like your steak cooked
so medium rare you close your eyes and
touch and take your pulse because
exactly there
is the same texture
of a steak it's sort of lightly bouncing
it gives a little bit but it's just soft
enough to understand that it's medium
rare
and my final tip behind any great steak
make sure you've got someone to share it
with enjoy
[Music]
number nine this is a very important
tip
which i've forgotten about come on i'm
joking no here we go